hi everyone my name's Tamra chambers and
this is cameras never seen today I am
finishing up the Cornetto trilogy with
the world's end and honestly I'm a
little sad to see it like be finished I
haven't heard very much about the
world's end I know that the first one
was like a zombie film and then there
buddy-cop and this one's kind of like
they're sci-fi but other than that I
know a lot less people have seen it than
the other two I know people used to say
it's the weakest one I wrote the world's
end predictions give them to me you have
about an hour black heart emoji and then
martin freeman saying what's bike so
without further ado we'll jump straight
to it
what's the matter you've never used
shortcuts before
[Music]
ah I might have an unpopular opinion
about this Phil you guess I loved this
movie also yes Martin Freeman again but
with what seems like a lead role versus
just like a really small bit piece so
you jumped from these five grade school
guys to these five adults men and Simon
Pegg is going around as this kind of
loser character who wants to hold on to
his past trying to get the guys to go
back so they can do the pub crawls that
they never made and he's playing a such
a different character but the biggest
surprise and and in such a good way it's
Nick Frost's character who is this sober
a businessman he doesn't show well he's
so likable in this movie and it's really
exciting to watch him play something so
different
get it cast is like a bird o P best
friend type kind of and it's cool to see
you take a turn so the guys do not want
to go and do this pub crawl but Gary
convinces them and she's the worst simon
Pegg's character Gary King is awful but
I love her in this I think he's so like
you I don't know he's just very upfront
about being awful and everyone calls him
out on being awful you're the worst Gary
King it's I'd like that they're calling
him out on it I wrote down I know that
this is a sci-fi movie but so far it's
not that and I would just be happy to
watch this movie about these old friends
reconnecting to do the pub crawl I think
I'm picking up on a few more things than
I did in the first two just because I
know what to look for every pub name
kind of told what was happening in the
story through the fourth pub and Gary in
Centennial Hall of his friends used the
worst he goes into the bathroom and
invites this younger boy to go with him
and then they get into a fight and
that's when the sci-fi elements comes
into play and I completely forgot that
this just wasn't like
the og hangover movie you know I knew it
was coming the whole time it still felt
very exciting and like surprising so the
friends come in they see that there's
this robot with blue blood thing on the
ground and they start taking out all
these robots decides that the town has
been taken over by robots
I love the immediate belief in this they
all are on board I also loved the gore
aspects in these movies all three of
them aren't I wouldn't call it horror at
all but they've got this insane amount
of gore that's done really well in a
movie that I would think would look WAY
cheesier than it ends up looking the
effects of the deaths in Hot Fuzz are
just are really good a seaman dislike
the gore and the blue blood squirting
out and like the the mechanics of the
robots are really cool sorry not robots
robot means slave so they're all super
drunk they decide that if they don't
continue with their plan to do the pub
crawl than every one of the robots
robots will know they're trying to
figure out what's happening but they're
also trying to do it with beer brain is
ridiculous you cannot get literally
anything done when you're drinking beer
it's just impossible
tequila fight Oh God 10:54 there's a
crazy guy named basil hotel Steve what's
really going on it's very they live also
which I've seen now I can say and you
let reference the name of that movie so
they're out pub nine Andy is getting
very upset with all of the happenings
going on abruptly takes out Martin
Freeman's character and then ripped open
his shirt and yells I love this part and
used by far my favorite character in
this and then I get there's an
incredible fight sequence this long
really well choreographed Simon Pegg is
an incredible physical mover actor is
which is the correct term for it they do
a call back again with jumping over
fences it's just blah oh there's this
girl that had tried to kiss Andy earlier
to get his DNA
you know ass tricky women um so she
takes his wedding ring off with her
mouth and swallows it and she's like
trying to seduce him so that he'll stop
you know destroying all of her robot
brethren and she's like I want you
inside me and like okay and then
clutches our stomach takes his wedding
ring back it is just uh I set this in
the last one there's just such good
moments of seriousness Gary has been in
the hospital for self-harm and the
beginning I thought he was just in a a
it's sad it's really really sad and the
character of Gary is so sad he's just
holding on to these glory days of high
school they make it to the final pub the
world and Gary opens up a beer spout and
it triggers this whole thing go
underground and that's where the network
is the flow bots are there then they
escape the town in this fiery fury and
you're like okay well it's going to be
like Shaun of the Dead where everything
goes back to normal and then oh man what
funny weird thing that was a year ago no
the whole world is in this
post-apocalyptic like state of life now
Andy is telling this story to these
children there's the great moment with
the Cornetto flapper wrapper flapping
away if you know anything about me and
my video game love it's that I'm
obsessed with fallout and so I love that
kind of vibe so those folks so so much
and I dug it I just wish that there was
a second movie and then like I wish that
there was more to watch honestly this
left me just wanting way more content
than there is and this is my unpopular
opinion this is my favorite out of a
street film I'm really excited to see
the prediction so I'm pretty sure
everyone's going to be like oh you don't
like it as much but it's still fun no
this is my favorite one
then Hot Fuzz then Sean's the dead and
those Shaun of the Dead was such a good
film just if I have to rank them
obligatory political joke about the
world ending in the real world Oh funny
cuz it's true when you heard about the
Golden Mile you will be tempted to do
one of your own a couple years back with
some other youtubers I actually did
drinking around the world at Disney
World
where you get one drink in every country
in Epcot and I left around Mexico
you'll love the role reversal of Simon
Pegg and Nick Frost and appreciate their
acting talents even further yet they're
incredible together they work so well
off of each other and it was just oh
well good what was that
la Hammer chambers what did you think
about the World's End oh I'll just let
you know right now
all right samer chambers everyone please
I hope it's your favorite I love it the
most out of the whole trilogy oh good
I'm so glad I thought that because a lot
of people don't agree I'm sure you all
think it's good as well but like I don't
think many people love this the most and
it just is must buy you room you'll feel
really bad for simon Pegg's character
when you learn the reason he's doing it
yes I wasn't expecting that at all I was
expecting him to have a growing moment
at the end but to see the self harm was
so sad and something that is a really
important thing to be portrayed I think
on stream and I I think they handled it
in a good way let me know what you think
I think that they handled it really well
so like let's go in come here
that was so nice you may miss the tiny
thread that connects this movie with the
two others in the trilogy I don't I
think it still connects well maybe
because I'm watching them boom boom boom
right in a row you know that might help
they're all so fresh in my memories I
think a lot of people are thrown by the
switch of characters with Simon Pegg and
Nick Frost because I think a lot of
people relate to simon Pegg's character
in the first two film even though he
plays vastly different characters I
think people relate to those characters
the go getter but also you know
sometimes the slacker if you do relate
to him really well going into the third
one and just be like well I don't relate
to being an asshole could be a little
off-putting
that's like theory I have I don't know
maybe not hair flips for unpopular
opinions everyone thank you so much for
watching check out my Twitter this week
I'm going to be putting up definitely a
poll for my next one I really don't know
what I'm doing for my next one I'm
looking for something in the veins of a
weird 80s classic that I've not seen
maybe it's what I'm feeling
we'll see thank you so much for watching
and I will see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you